[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the dave ramsey show that's where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life
we talk about your money we talk about
your calling the work that you were
created to do we talk about your
mental emotional health and your
relationships we talk about it all it is
life because
it's real and it's right there in front
of you and you got two
options you either participate or you
shrink back
and sit on the sidelines i'm ken coleman
host of the ken coleman show which is
part of the ramsey
solutions network i am a ramsey
personality uh
co-host the show on a regular basis with
dave
and i'm joined by my colleague john
dolone host of the dr john delony show
on the ramsey solutions network and he
is of course
a ransom personality and a frequent
co-host of the show so if you are new to
the dave ramsey show
and thus new to us uh let john and i
just tell you
that uh we're excited to be together now
uh
just a quick intro here on what i do and
what john does i'm focused on
calling career your work
work that matters simply put i believe
that you were created to fill a unique
role
in your work through your work that
means you are tremendously needed
but then john it also means that you got
to do it because see
purposeful work isn't about us it's not
about money and notoriety and fame and
power
it's about the contribution that we were
created to make and so our purpose is
actually not about us it's about
others it's always about others and so
we've got this weird
view of work john here at ramsey
solutions
most of the world thinks that you work
to live to get a paycheck
to be able to pay the bills it was a
little left over make some memories
right but we believe that we were
created to work now we're not talking
about created to be a workaholic right
and put all of your identity in your
work at college that's not what we're
saying right we are saying
that you were created to contribute to
this world right through the talent you
have
what you do best through passion which
is the actual love
of the work those of you who love to
work with your hands and create
something
that's a gift to the world and then to
create a result from that work
that matters to you because you see the
direct contribution
so that's what we think so that's what i
focus on and then john uh
you know you focus on the mental the
emotional health relationships because
if you look at purpose i think it's two
buckets and you and i cover both of them
right
one is i've got a purpose to be who i'm
supposed to be in my relationships
and also in my work you cover the
relationships and the human aspect
talk a little bit about your philosophy
and your methodology i i think
i mean you nailed it you can't go
through life alone
and you and i have we've grown up in an
ethos that is
this is all about you figure it out
yourself do it yourself accomplish
yourself
and your happiness and your joy and your
soul and your completion exist out there
yeah
right if you can just go achieve it
it'll you'll sleep well
right and if you can do it by yourself
you should do it by yourself
you don't need other people we don't
need other people and can those two
things
just from a biochemistry
perspective is wrong yeah it's just
deceitful that's right we were made
to work hard and made to connect we were
made to connect
big time and without those two things
every alarm system we has
goes off every inflammation response we
have goes off and we find ourselves
spinning and achieving and numbing and
look around man
we're seeing 50 100 years of go achieve
your way to it
distract your way to it and then here we
are that's it so john you also know this
that when you're not happy
in your work life and you don't see that
connection to what am i supposed to
contribute to this world
that can begin to affect all of your
relationships that's everything that's
where it's so
and vice versa when you're not when me
and my wife aren't whole at home
yes when i have not been a good parent
at home
you can't be all you're supposed to be
in the office absolutely not right it
works together
it does and so john and i work together
we've done uh we've done a couple of ken
coleman shows where i'll bring john in
and we'll say hey all right you've got
some toxic workplace stuff going on and
hello i'm talking to
three quarters of the world uh so today
we're going to take money questions but
we're also going to take your questions
about
relationships in your home or uh
in in the workplace you've got a toxic
leader john and i love to tag team those
okay because there's a dual response
there
so if you're just miserable at work
miserable at home
this is your show and i'm going to say
this you know zach bennett sitting in
for kelly
daniel today he'll change your name yeah
we'll change the location for where
you're calling
i want john for people to feel safe
today to go you know what
i'm a phone call away from getting some
clarity
on what i need to do to get out of the
rut
the hole that i'm in they're one phone
call away that's right and one step
further
we're in a moment in history where
everybody
is on edge everybody oh yeah and
triggered
just on edge right and here's the thing
i talked about it on my show this
morning and i'll continue to beat this
drum when you are on edge
this is not myth this is not fantasy
when you are on edge
when you feel like you are not safe
someone's taking something from you
your amygdala literally turns off your
frontal lobe because it doesn't want you
sitting at the
in the cave going is that a nice tiger a
sweet tiger it just wants you to run man
just want you to fight and so
if you woke up this morning angry if
um you woke up this morning in a state
of what is happening for my family what
is happening for my country what does
that yeah
call us can i even pursue my dream
because all of a sudden
we got a different president in and we
got a different what is that going to
affect my purposes
kitchen can i even and it's like hey
let's take it to my family
call me tell you something else i want
to i want to put the call out
for those of you who are hurting from
being out of work for a long time let's
not forget that
when covet 19 hit it wrecked
it wrecked people's lives sideways john
sent me something this weekend i haven't
even show i haven't told james this
uh so james i'm having coffee saturday
morning
and uh sitting there and a text pops up
from dr john delony
i'm like oh and this is what he sent me
he was doing some research and there's a
guy by the name of andrew oswalt
i'm just going to tee you up on this
yeah uh who is an economist at the
university of warwick in the uk
and basically says that no other
circumstance produces a larger decline
in mental health
and well-being than being involuntarily
so laid off
furloughed out of work so then being
nothing is producing a larger decline in
mental health and well-being than being
involuntarily out of work for six months
or more listen to this john this blew me
away
it is the worst thing that can happen he
says equivalent to the death of a spouse
and a there's a direct quote a kind of
bereavement
in its own right so john you and i do
combine forces on this this is a
seriously traumatic event if you're out
of work yes
or in work that you hate right or when
you are working for
somebody else's pleasure you're not
working to help somebody right
you were working for somebody else's
flourishing right
you know you and i we we've talked about
this privately
uh when our friend mike rowe was here
this summer yeah and he
mentioned something that i'd never
thought of that when we told 30 million
americans y'all are essential
we told 300 other million americans you
know what y'all just go home that's
exciting we don't need you we'll just
send you a check
yes and when you read that research we
basically told everybody
listen you all have less value that's it
just go home we'll mill you money we
don't need you
and that set off a chemical storm in our
hearts and minds that have made us
depressed not to mention foreign decades
of messaging that says if you don't go
to college you're a second class citizen
all the citizens you go into the trades
you're a loser you're a loser
so here's the deal triple eight eight
two five five two two five remember at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
phone lines are open john and i are
coming right back we're gonna help you
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
welcome back america this is the dave
ramsey show ken coleman and dr
john deloney taking you through this
hour and uh we are the ramsey
personalities
that focus on calling
career work that matters and
mental emotional relationship health and
john we put the word out in the first
segment and
boy oh boy hit him up man we rang the
bell people
need some help so hey we're really
excited now we're still going to take
your money calls
it was i was telling jeremy breeland uh
who leads all of the personalities i
said yeah
delony and i are hosting the dave ramsey
show first hour here and
boy we're going to take some money
questions i don't know how good the
answers are going to be but sell the
truck man but you sell the truck yes
worst case scenario sell it can you go
wrong
if you are about to call with a question
like hey man i got this truck
we're just going to tell you to sell it
yeah it's pretty much the extent of our
knowledge
keep the phone lines open please because
we're going to tell you to sell the
truck i love that all right good stuff
all right triple eight eight two five
five two five excuse me five two two
five i skipped a two
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
phone lines are open and we're gonna
start it off with patty
who's joining us in philadelphia
pennsylvania patty
how can we help hi hi thank you good to
talk with you gentlemen
i am a work for a small
company it's a landscaping construction
company
and the business manager office manager
you know
everything and i'm in a position where
the owner
really relies on me to make some pretty
significant financial decisions and
operational
uh decisions he's a very he's very good
at his craft but
not very good at his business and i'm
really i'm really starting to
resent that i'm put in that position
i i can do it i have the training to do
it but i don't
i don't think he really understands the
importance of what he's asking me to do
and
i i'm feeling resentful and i'm feeling
like i'm really getting tired of it oh
all right so i'm gonna let john jump in
on the feelings of resentment but i i
do want to know a little bit of
background on this have you talked to
him about this to say hey you're
you're asking me to do some pretty
heavy-duty stuff
and i just want to make sure you
understand that that what you're asking
me to do makes you
really really hands off and this is what
i'm
feeling about this have you had that
conversation with him
i've had the conversation that um
asking him does he understand that he's
asking me to make some pretty
significant
decisions i've i've not delved into the
feeling part of it
uh as yet so your
beneath your question is a value
question
and yes why it seems like
on just listening to you seems like this
guy
trusts you a lot seems like he really
cares about you
and has said man here's the keys to the
kingdom there's something about
you that doesn't sit that sit well with
you is it a is he not compensating you
enough is it because
hey i don't want to run a business i
don't mind running the books what's
what's the value question
what's the value concern here um he
definitely does trust me and i do
appreciate that
okay i know that he cares for me um
because sometimes uh frequently
when i give him an answer or suggestion
that he doesn't want to hear
like i want to buy this very expensive
item
what do you think and i say i think that
we do not have the money for it
and this is why and then he kind of acts
like a little boy whose mom just told
him no
and that's getting old yeah yeah yeah
so i got a quick question let me jump in
is it is there also
a sense of pressure that you feel he's
putting you under he's asking because
you've touched on it twice
and i feel like maybe you've got some
fear there like this guy's asking me to
make some huge decisions and it's not my
company i don't like feeling that way is
that also going on
um i don't have a whole lot of fear
around that because i'm pretty sure i
won't get myself in trouble i know what
to say
no all right but he's he loves to
when he asks you to do something and it
works he loves taking credit for those
moments but if he asks you to buy
something y'all can't afford and you
tell him no
he does a temper tantrum or if you buy
it and you look squeezed at the end of
the month he blames you for being inept
right
well he doesn't really blame me but
there's a lot of there's a lot of
unsaid words and a lot of energy
floating around in the office that i
would rather not have floating around
walking there you go so
whenever i hear the word resentment in a
relationship
resentment is a product of comparison
i'm doing more than you i'm carrying
more than you it happens a lot in
marriages i do the dishes i do
this i take care of the baby and all you
do is and what i'll tell you is this
once you get to resentment
resentment is the death
it is the death trajectory of any
relationship in the world
and so what i'll tell you is
resentment's often a choice
and it's you have a lot of control over
this it could be
your choices i don't want this life i
don't want this
job i don't want this pressure i'm going
to let him know in a controlled planned
conversation not
in a fight hey i'm i'm just got i'm
uncomfortable now
i i don't want to do this if you're
going to keep asking me to who run your
business
i don't want to be a ceo i just want to
run books and i promise you you're going
to find somebody in town that would love
to have an ethical great bookkeeper that
that person will exist
or you sit down and say i'm going to
stop resenting him
he trusts me and loves me he's immature
and you have to line up boss after boss
in america under that
label right yeah i'm gonna choose to not
be resentful because i'm poisoning
myself hoping he's gonna die that's
right
because he's probably not going to
change and i think that patty what you
need to understand is is you have yet to
share with him your real emotions and i
think because you guys have such a great
relationship
because he trusts you so much that if
you handle this in the right posture
just say hey can i tell you what's been
going on behind the scenes
you asked me to guard this company i
feel like i'm the chief guardian
and i love it uh and i i'm not gonna
blow it or screw up but when i do what
you actually want me to do
on your best interest and you kind of
get mad and kind of create this tension
between us
it puts me in a really resentful mode
because i'm actually
doing the thing for you that you want me
to do and i actually love to do
and i'm the most fierce protector of you
in this company do you understand how
that makes me feel i think you
owe him that conversation because i
think if he hears it in the spirit of
humility to go oh wow
patty really does have my back and i am
acting like a
like a seven-year-old boy who had his
fire truck taken away
oh okay what we get to see right there
uh patty is you get to see oh okay
he's willing to try and that will also
help with what john's saying where
you've got to expect it and deflect it
and decide i'm not going to be resentful
and that goes to
an employee that goes to a spouse and
here's the thing and i said i'm going to
say it again
don't wait until he comes in and says
hey i want to buy all new mowers we're
buying all new mowers
and that be the moment you snap and you
say i can't we can't afford that he says
ah figured out and then you blow up on
him
you got to say hey on friday at noon i
want to order in lunch i just want to
talk about the state of the company
let's plan on i'm gonna tell you some
things have been on my heart and mind
give them some preparation for it
and same as you don't yell at your
spouse
you know when the dishes aren't done you
figure it out that night everybody be
mature and then that weekend you say hey
we just need to talk
here's the good news the silver lining
for this
patty and john i heard this it doesn't
sound like he's overruling her it just
sounds like he gets a little pouty and
he gets upset because she
he said she said he couldn't have his
toy so the fact that he's not overruling
you and running the business in the
ground we heard no evidence of that it's
not happening and he's not unethical
he's not so she's got to go okay
i've just got to be okay that he's
immature on this and i'm not going to be
able to make those changes for him he's
going to have to do
that by being honest with him and
sharing this with him in a safe way
not a complaining attacking way
hospitable ways a good way to say that
then we got a chance but even if he
doesn't fully ever turn the corner
then that's what i mean by expected and
deflected right oh boy he wants this
brand new shiny thing and we just can't
afford it
he's gonna gripe about a little bit but
what's his pattern oh he kind of doesn't
talk to you for two days and then
he really needs me and all of a sudden
he gets an infusion of good attitude and
we're going to be okay
and that's where john you experience
this more uh
on your show but difficult people exist
and sometimes we're the difficult people
and we can't just decide to quit because
sometimes the people we have to work
with
can sometimes step on our toes or be
obnoxious or of truth or whatever we got
to learn how to be big boys and
big girls i think we all have those
moments of course
when i'm the big kid and then there's
the time i'm the whining bra
of course all of us have that yeah and
if i can recognize
yeah i'm entering into winey brat season
i need to shut up
all right look what we got coming up
next segment uh oh
mary's on the line and she's got a
question about navigating political
conflicts in the family
well that doesn't affect anybody else
but we'll still try to help i haven't
married my family
we're diving into that stuff next this
is good
radio this is the dave ramsey show
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman and dr john deloney with you
on the dave ramsey show
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five
five two two five taking your calls
about your life and your money and also
what john and i specialize on
are you just sick and tired of your job
monday
mornings are nothing more than sheer
misery for you as soon as you get in the
car to head to work
you're struggling emotionally struggling
with mental health
relationship issues in your life or at
the office
john and i are going to take those calls
that's where we specialize triple eight
eight two five five two two five all
right here we go
i teased it mary's calling in from st
louis got some some political conflicts
and stress
in the family mary tell us about it
hi dr dean ken um so grateful for you
guys
um dr d you've been giving us tons of
great advice about how to handle
conflict stemming from political
tensions
it's been so helpful i'm not i'm not
super great with it as you can see right
so i'm john and i fight about politics
every day in the office that's what he's
not telling you that's right
well it's been better than nothing well
i appreciate you're a kind kind person
thank you
thanks um so yesterday dave made a funny
comment about the advice being great
assuming the other person that you're
dealing with wasn't mentally ill
but what if that person does have a
history of mental illness and emotional
problems
and boundary issues can you please throw
out some healthy ways
and exit strategies to end politically
divisive interrogation
and yes for me it has been interrogation
and could you please share some handy
phrases that could excuse yourself from
even going there
i want to live out proverbs 15 1 which
says a gentle answer turns away wrath
but a harsh word stirs up anger i mean
that's such a
great question there's a couple of
things uh globally here
one is um yeah actually um
talked to somebody today dave and i
yesterday were
the the call mary's referring to is um
dave and i yesterday talked about an
instagram post i don't watch the news
kid you know this y'all give me a hard
time back there
that um i'm more interested in local
stuff and what's in people's hearts and
minds and not on tv and
um i posted something with the word
unity in it
and you would have thought man i was the
second co it was wild stuff
i learned all about myself i learned
more about myself from the
the internet's comments yes and dave and
i were talking about on the air
um he said man i didn't know you were a
liberal i found out i had to find out on
instagram and i said damn i told you i
was a liberal in my
in interview and we were laughing
carrying on being silly
and we got to laughing about
man if somebody if people have mental
illness they're not going to hear you
and you know what i shouldn't have been
laughing about that because there's
folks like mary there's folks like me
there's folks like
millions of people who've got people
with that actually struggle with
mental health issues it's not something
to make fun of dave and i were having a
good time but
i think you're right mary and i think
you treat this the same as you treat any
hard conversation
with somebody um who believes something
different than you
which is compassion and you just decide
to not go to war
if somebody wants to interrogate you you
do have permission whether they have
mental health issues whether they have
any sort of
of challenges with communication you
have a right to be safe
and you have a right to your boundaries
and i often will tell folks mental
health
responses mental health challenges are
context not an excuse
yeah just because somebody has a mental
health issue does not give them
permission to treat you poorly to
interrogate you to beat you up to be
ugly to you or anything like that
and so when somebody does and i've got
this in my family when somebody comes at
you with
can you believe i will stop and say hey
we're not talking politics here
not going to do that today i'm not going
to have this conversation i do though
i want to hear about how little susie's
doing i don't hear how your job is going
um or let's just hug we're not going to
do it and i'm silly about it at my house
because i'll say hey we're just going to
hug it out
but i i don't engage with conversations
with people who are not interested in
listening to me yeah
all right and that's a it's the way i
navigate it that's why i like talking
with you ken because
you hear different conversations i hear
different conversations
and the thing i like about you ken is
that nobody knows where we're ever gonna
land on anything and that makes my heart
feel good yeah
how do you approach that conversation
well i think very similar to what you're
saying i think that you know she's
she's thinking how do i say it in a very
kind gentle way you know instead of the
hard
you know heisman trophy stance you know
stop we're not doing that because that
can also
push you in a tough situation and i
think it's a i think it's a preemptive
strike i think in her situation it's to
sit down and go hey
i love you deeply and i know you like to
talk about this stuff
but i actually don't like to talk about
not because not because i disagree with
you or i think that you're wrong
i it just makes me uncomfortable and i
would just prefer that we don't do it so
i just want you to know ahead of time
it's not anything that you've done it's
not you it's me right i'm just not
comfortable i'm doing this in other
areas of my life
and it just it just it's just nobody's
ever going to see eye to eye
and and neither one of us are going to
solve actually any major national
problems or local actual policy problems
by fighting amongst ourselves and so
i just think for our relationship and
this is me my standard not yours
i don't want you to feel bad about tiger
you can talk about it around me
and i'm not going to interject and i'm
not going to debate you but if you don't
mind i just want to create a thing where
we're just going to talk about it and i
think i'd be preemptive there
so that we put a boundary up before it
happens in the moment
for thanksgiving and for christmas um
we had people come for christmas and i
actually sent an email out and said
here's the topics we are not going to
discuss
yeah that's a preemptive started out
there right we had a great time yeah and
a couple of times it started to kind of
eek into there
there was some hands put up yeah like
we're doing that yeah because i love you
and if we can't be civil about it i'm
not well you're not
whatever the consequence let's just
don't do it yeah
and and i think you know i don't think
i've ever talked about this on the show
so this is this is kind of fun and i
think
uh what i want the audience to know is
that i used to be in politics full-time
what you knew this no i didn't know this
no yeah i worked uh
i worked on a congressional race at the
age of 19. my life just got so much 1994
and then i was working for the governor
of virginia at the age of 22.
okay so i was a special assistant to
governor jim gilmore
and so i there was a season in my life
where i thought i was called
to politics i had a
career in calling crisis in my early 30s
because i
lost the taste for it gotcha i was
irritated with both sides of the aisle
so don't anybody doing a bunch of
guesswork and send me emails
which by the way i don't read any emails
that are negative so
if i say something right now that
somehow offends you you can email i'm
never going to read it so
spare yourself i will send it to me you
you enjoy that kind of stuff yeah
but here's what i found out i lost the
fire in the belly i lost the passion for
the work
and the results of the mission yeah that
career crisis is now what informs all
the work that i do right so you didn't
know any of that but here's my point
having worked in politics and being a
guy who though i no longer work in it
and i don't want to work in it and by
the way i don't want to return to it
either so
let's go ahead and make that
announcement
i have learned of a really clear lesson
that i think would help us all when it
comes to
political talk and co-workers and family
and friends
i have never one time john in a debate
with a family member
a friend or a co-worker i have never one
time changed their mind
you did you didn't you didn't uh no
argue someone into submission no
never once that the the end of a
political debate even if it was
not nasty and i don't really have nasty
ones but never one time have i
had a political discussion with somebody
who's on the opposite end of the
spectrum or
completely on the other side of an issue
and not one time they went ken
boy i tell you what i made my points and
i really really believe my points but
after you made your points i got to tell
you i see it exactly the way you see it
thank you ken for enlightening me and
setting me on
the right path has that ever happened
for you zero times
so therefore i've never
i've never twitter response or facebook
responded
somebody to change somebody's mind yeah
but i will tell you this
at my house i've had people spend the
night at my house
that would have made bernie sanders go
whoa that's pretty far over there yeah
and i've had people spend the night at
my house that trump would have been like
ah it's probably a little bit too far to
the right for me let's all bring it back
a little bit yeah
everyone's welcome at my table yeah and
we're going to serve food together
and we're going to talk and we're going
to figure some of this out somebody a
an astute listener one of the dave
ramsey show one time wrote in
and said i get the sense that you and
dave
think differently on some things and we
talked about it and i said
yep we have very
very matching boundaries i mean values
we want to help people we love people we
care about our faith we care about our
families
we have different beliefs and that's
beautiful because our values are
together
and dave wants to help somebody and
sometimes he wants to help him by
letting him have it and i want to i want
to help him by hugging him out
our beliefs are going to change and if i
do the hard work of reading and learning
and listening my beliefs are going to
change all over my lifetime and i hope
they do but my value is going to be rude
and anchored in
and i think if we did this value belief
work across the country you'd see a
connection
happen from the floor up man let me
remind everybody something i say on the
ken coleman show all the time
the one thing that every human being on
the planet can unify around then there
might be more than one thing
but one thing for sure oh i'm gonna use
it you know we can be unified around is
that we all want to make a difference in
this world
we want to make a difference let's be
about that this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr
john deloney taking your calls triple
eight eight two five
two two five before we go back to the
phones let's uh
let's take a pause here and remember
that 2020 was
really wacky and your 2020 taxes may be
a bit more complicated because of it so
if you drew unemployment at any point
this year
keep in mind you may have to pay taxes
on it this year
unemployment checks are taxable income
another big thing to keep in mind
is remote working if you left your
resident state
to work remotely from another state you
may have to pay state taxes
to two states so the point is a lot
changed and it may have changed your
taxes so if you're unsure if 2020's
major tax is different
take our tax quiz this will give you
some peace of mind so you know
what you're facing and then what you
need to do
text the phrase tax quiz so those two
words no spaces
tax quiz text that to 33789 to find out
what your tax situation really looks
like
tax quiz text that phrase with no space
to three three seven eight nine triple
eight eight two five
five two two five is the number let's go
to knoxville tennessee
where jack joins us jack how can we help
yeah i was calling in today to ask you
all what you do about the situation i'm
in so
i've got a job well i've got three jobs
actually but i really
my full-time job i work for the united
states government
and uh i really love what i do
but i hate i don't hate the people i
work with but they make my job miserable
what do you do man so i work for the
united states
geological survey and uh just measure
rivers and creeks and lakes and
manage the sounds like you're out of the
office a good bit yes or no
yeah oh yeah so tell me how your
co-workers are making you miserable i
want to know the specifics
well i guess every morning when you go
into work that
you go into the office get your work
truck get all your stuff ready to go out
for the day
right oh uh
there's so there's only three of us to
work them off that's me and two other
guys and
one of them's kind of the head guy and
he's like oh what are you gonna get done
today
and it makes your job it puts so much on
you that
there's no way that you can get it done
in
eight to ten hours i mean i almost i
can't i may be getting a little touch of
burnout
and it may be because of him or them
is he penalizing you when he gives you
that much work to do
are you having to work uh longer than
eight to ten hours a day to get it done
or are you going home at normal time and
you're not getting it done and he's
busting your chops about it
what's going on i'm i'm just working
longer than eight to ten hours whatever
it takes to get the job done and then
going home and spending the rest time
with my family or
well you got two other jobs yeah so yeah
so you love the work you love the work
itself
and you've gotta i love what i do yeah
yeah so
have you talked to this leader to say
hey um the stuff you're piling on me
i can't get it all done in a day and are
you aware that i'm working this many
hours but i'm not getting overtime
oh yeah and he's kind of like well this
job comes first
you know what needs to be done all right
so here's the thing so
the way i describe um your situation
jack
on the ken coleman show is you're doing
the right thing in the wrong place
um you've got an unhealthy leader it's
become a toxic
work environment and there is little to
no hope that that's going to change
you've had the conversation he's kind of
like
tough go pound sand and so
now you resent the very existence of the
guy and i we don't even need to dive
into whatever
uh guy number two is doing that's making
you so miserable
so the good news here is you know what
the
work is that you love and so now we've
got to be a big boy we got to go all
right
can i walk away from this thing right
now am i that miserable
and uh if i can't put up with it any
longer
can i walk away from it financially if
the answer's no the answer is you can't
put up with a little bit longer you're a
tough guy
you can bite the stick you can be the
bigger man but you need to start looking
today and the good news is you know the
kind of work that you want to do
so now starting as soon as you hang up
this phone call
you've got to start looking for that
work somewhere else
and you go okay i know the kind of work
i love and this is an exercise john
where again
you know jack can just sit down with a
pencil and paper like i've got right
here and go okay
what are all the things i love about
this job well i love this this this this
and this
and and so we we already know that he
loves it but we want to get real
specific
and those become the menu items if you
will
as you begin to look you know if you
pull a recipe you know i love to cook
kind of for fun
and i always love getting the recipe
card you know getting out and go what
all's in this
well that's what we're looking for what
are the ingredients
to this job that he loves
and now we're going to go look for that
and the good news is we can find that
now we know what a toxic environment is
like
and so this is what a lot of people
don't do in the
research process for new jobs or a
different job or in the interview
process
you have got to look for the signs that
you're very acutely aware of
and so you ask the kind of question
what's it like here how do you handle
workload how do you handle feedback you
know he knows now what he wants
he's got to match it up in the
marketplace and so that's the steps he
needs to take guys working three jobs
this is going to eat him alive if he
doesn't get out of there that's exactly
right
and i'd love to see him there is a
market for guys who will work beyond
eight to ten hours because that's the
right thing to do and i'm gonna get this
job done because i'm a person of
excellence and i'm a hard worker
that guy's gonna find work that's right
and i'd love to see him
have one job yeah that he's getting paid
what he's worth that is putting in the
hard work he goes so i'm tired and then
he can spend the rest of that energy and
focus on his family
you can tell he loves them and uh man
we had more people that just wanted to
cut out the nonsense and we just want to
go to work and we're going to work our
butts off
and go home tired i don't want the drama
let's just get it done
man well this this case folks listen in
jack's situation is the
is half of the equation of why so many
people are unhappy at work
pre-covered the number was 68 of
americans were unhappy their work the
number was 80
internationally this is pre-coveted and
there's two major reasons for that
number one you're not in your sweet spot
which i teach is where you're using your
talent what you do best
to do work you love your passion to
produce results
that matter deeply to you that's your
mission so people aren't in their sweet
spot of course you're gonna you know
just it becomes just this utilitarian
function and it slowly just
beats the death out it just beats you to
death because you're like
i i there's no meaning to this work for
me but the
other reason john is poor leadership
like we see here right here's a guy
who should be looking at jack going this
dude
he's my rock star man it's working long
crazy hours
to get the job done that i've poured on
top of him
and the cold in the cold the heat yeah
being away from his family he's working
two other jobs
and this guy's just like tough man this
is your priority as opposed to going
wait a second
we got work to do we're a small team of
three how do i help jack
not actually begin to feel burned out
right
but this leader is so pathetic yeah i
mean pathetic
and and by the way this this goes from
poor leadership where you you're not
exhibiting the characteristics and
you're not good at your job
to then it becomes it borderline abusive
you're going okay ken relax
no because you as a leader
as a boss hold over top of people
maybe one of the most powerful
extrinsic motivators there is and that's
the ability to fire them
well and their livelihood as we talked
about earlier
it's also we're holding over them a a
core psychological component of their
wellness yes their their purpose and
work
yes and their food on their families
plate yes and their role
and the ability to provide and then the
ability to contribute
yes and leaders stop
stop this i mean get help goodness
gracious
there's a reason why we've got the
entree leadership division here at
ramsey solutions
the reason we do the entree leadership
program there are books that you can
read
you can actually build your leadership
skill you can be
a zero on a scale of one to ten and you
can actually
learn how to lead but john this is a
this is a massive problem around the
world absolutely it's poor leadership
and we've got we're in a season now
we've got to have leaders stepping up
all over the place from janitorial
staffs to ceos and everybody in between
we've got to start doing the things the
right way all right folks
i can't believe it an hour down we got
to go we had too much fun i want to
thank our producer james childs
zach bennett sitting in for kelly daniel
today as our associate producer and call
screener i want to thank my pal
dr john deloney and we want to thank you
america i'm ken coleman
and this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the dave ramsey show and it's where
america hangs out to have the
important conversations of life money
relationships work
that matters deeply to you
getting out of debt making more money
healing in relationships
mental emotional health we're talking
life we're talking about every facet of
it i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague dr john deloney and we
are what they call around here ramsay
personalities
dr john dolone hosts the dr john deloney
show
on the ramsey network his website is
johndaloney.com i host the ken coleman
show
yes we know how creative those show
titles are we go all out we spend hours
and hours and hours and tens of dollars
does those
names seven dollars and i'm at
kencoleman.com but we're thrilled to be
a part
of this wonderful place called ramsey
solutions
uh if you're new to the show you'll see
and hear us
as we co-host with dave on just about a
weekly basis as we all
roll through here and we always enjoy it
when we get to be together because
we're not money personalities you're
focusing on
relationships and mental and emotional
health and i'm focusing on
purpose in your life and in your work
and those things intertwine they do
entertain very closely and so the phones
are blowing up so you've got a
toxic work situation toxic co-workers
you have no idea what you want to do
with your life
you know what you want to do with your
life you're not quite sure how to get
there
you've got some mental and emotional
issues or family members that do
well all of that that's what we do
are you and your wife maybe you
discovered in 2020 you'll have different
political views and now you can't even
sit with each other on the couch you're
really after these political
uh attention calls man they're just yeah
we're taking buildings apart and work
places apart and church is a part come
on man yeah let's go let's figure it out
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is a number and here we
go sean is up in louisville kentucky
sean how can we help
hi ken and john how you guys doing today
well we're living the dream what what
can we do for you
uh i got a bit of a dilemma and it's
almost like the similar to the last
caller
i'm in a job that i've been doing for 23
years and it's become very toxic over
the past
probably year and um i've looked outside
and i'm
have an offer for another job and
it's gonna be about a twenty thousand
dollar pay cut
and uh i'm not sure if i should go for
it and take it
um a little background my wife and i
we're on baby step four five and six
great and uh we can afford the pay cut
but i'm not sure
if i just need to basically suck it up
and
stay where i'm at and keep the big money
that i'm making or
take that leap how much are you making
now
i make about 85 000 and
where i'm go where where i was offered
it's about 62 65
000 and and that's really
everywhere i've looked that's that's
what's going to happen it's going to be
a pay cut
is that a temporary situation in other
words
go ahead go ahead no you tell me is that
going to eventually like a year
year and a half 18 months i mean what is
the what does the trajectory look like
if you moved over to this new company i
eventually it will it will go up here
you know throughout the years but
i i don't believe that it'll ever reach
the potential
of where i'm at currently why is that
what is the work is it the same kind of
work
in a sense i'm a truck driver and the
truck driving that i do
i actually unload my truck physically
and this is going to be
and also i'm gone two nights a week from
home
and so i'm going to be going to a job
that's home every day
local and a lot less physical work with
it
and thus the difference in the pay scale
that's the difference yes
correct what what do you not like about
your current job
uh just a lot of uh
stuff like you know political stuff like
you know uh we can't deliver
this time we can't deliver that time uh
you know we
just just have to really watch our fees
and cues on
you know a lot of things and i just
really just want to come in and do my
job and go home
okay so let me challenge you for a
second based on what you just said sean
we're missing something i'm missing
something that says that this thing is
super toxic
because you've been there for 23 years
and you said in the last year it's
become more toxic
and a guy who says to me well ken i just
want to come in and do my job and go
home
feels like if you just do that you
should be okay if you're not
engaging in those conversations that are
obnoxious or whatever i guess
what am i missing here because i think
there's got to be a key deciding factor
on
on on how much longer you can put up
with
this toxicity because if we if we
say no to this current situation that
you've been offered
and we kick the can down the road which
i'm fine with i haven't really decided
where i'm at yet you're going to have to
confront
leaving this place eventually unless it
just all of a sudden gets better
do you understand where i'm at you agree
with that or disagree
i do i agree so
you know can you overcome this is this
something that you can go
i'm gonna expect this and i'm gonna
deflect this or is it just something
that's always gonna be in your face
and this is only a matter of time
that i'm not sure of um
i just think with covet everything's
changed
in this past year obviously and and
things are making it to where
actually i'm gone away from home more
and more and more
and i think ultimately what i really
want to do is have more home time with
my family but
now we're on it now we got it okay now
we've gotten to what's really going on
so here's where i want to challenge you
um i don't think that you have to take
this current job
but if you guys can absorb the 20 000
and it not make it super tight
there are other ways that you can kind
of come in and go well is there a little
side hustle that i've always wanted to
mess around with
that now that i'm home more and i've got
some more
balance in my life that i could do that
that's one option the other thing is for
you to take this opportunity as a sign
that it is time to leave and i'm gonna
look for some other things where
where i am driving um and i'm a really
valuable uh employee for somebody
because of all this experience of
driving and unloading stuff
and i'm going to look for some better
more lucrative opportunities
that don't have me on the road as a road
warrior i'm not sure you've exhausted
all of your options yet would you agree
with that or disagree
i will agree um i it's just
i i come to the point i guess where i
think like you like you said
it's time for a change and i'm just i'm
i'm
one person that is very scared of change
well but here's the deal we don't have
to make a change
sean until we've verified that it's
actually a really good move so no one's
saying you got to jump off a cliff
you know that's only romantic in movies
and stuff like that where they make this
big bold change
super scintillating and awesome and oh
that courage yeah there's no background
music bro yeah
this is real life so sean i'm telling
you to go find something else
that you've got the talent to do and you
can enjoy the work and you can make
somewhere close to that 85 000 if not a
little bit more
and not have to be a road warrior i
don't think that what i'm suggesting is
a needle in a haystack
and you don't think it is either so then
you go what am i really afraid of
you're afraid of making a decision that
hurts you
financially and sets you back well
brother you're in baby step four five
and six there's no chance of you doing
that that's fear lying to you
you're not going to do something dumb so
don't worry about doing something dumb
let's find something that you're going
to step into we go get qualified for it
if we have to
and then we get the opportunity they
offer to us and we say
peace i'm out over here and we walk with
a beautiful stride
shoulders back head up into the next
thing none of that is scary
don't move more of your calls coming up
this is the dave ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
so
the dave ramsey show continues i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
dr john dolone as we take your calls
about
life relationships mental health
relationship and emotional health
working on purpose i don't think you're
just sick and tired of working at j.o.b
you don't like it you're not even that
very good at it
you're miserable well life is too short
to be miserable on mondays and live for
the weekend
we'll take your calls around all those
things we'll take your money calls as
well triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to pocatello
idaho
one of my favorite places that i've
never been to because i just like saying
it i can say it all day long it's a
phonetical
playground you know where are you from
pocatello hey me too
i'd like to say pocatello yeah that'd be
fun to say just once
all right let's see how nick says it
nick how can we help
hey i'm doing great how are you guys uh
we're having a blast man what's going on
hey
nick is there a pocatello high school in
pocatello
if you can get us a couple of pocatello
high t-shirts and send them our way i'd
be grateful
you know what this is a great point
what's the mascot of pocatello high
i feel like it just changed it used to
be the indians oh oh
so it just changed you can't do that
anymore pocatello is coming around look
at that what is it what's the new one
i think it's the thunder i'm actually
not from pocatello i'm from utah
okay well i need to go for it man what's
up how can we help
yeah i'm in a really unique situation
i'm really blessed to have a job that i
love i'm a pilot
i fly a route between salt lake and
pocatello every day
okay my domicile is pocatello so in the
eyes of my company i live up here
but i live down in utah so i just
commute on monday up here and i can use
saturday back down to utah
okay so the time i'm up in pocatello is
the time i'm really supposed to be at
home
so i have like eight seven hours every
day that i'm up here
but i just don't well tuesday through
friday i have about eight hours
to you know be up here at home but i
was wondering what i could do to work i
had a retail job that i was working
before
like christmas and i did that but then
when the new year hit
you know that job ended because it was
just seasonal work and anyway i'm just
kind of
you know wondering what i could do i'm
just looking for something to do
and want to make some extra money and
yeah i'm a hard worker i think this is
fun
i think this is really fun this to me is
the blank canvas nick
because you know i obviously want you to
do your dream job and i think you're
doing that you know and outside of that
if we can get you in your sweet spot
where you're doing something you're good
at
and something you really enjoy doing
that creates a result that you go you
know what that's that's pretty cool man
i i dig that
and i just want you doing it in
pocatello that's all i care about
this is fantastic yeah you just want him
to work for the gift shop at the
local high school anything pocatello
that's what i'm rooting for nick
so nick let's put this to the test
what's something that you would just
you've always wondered about you'd love
to do it
and because we've got this extra time
during the day
during the week and there's no pressure
to perform and turn it into this big
time career what's something you've
always
wondered about um
recently i've been looking into coding
and
i just don't even know where to begin
with with something like that well
first thing we have to do is got to get
qualified to code so do you know how to
code
no great so this is awesome because
and there might be another answer here
nick but let's run this one out you've
always thought about coding you want to
code but you know
no idea where to start well we got to
get qualified okay and so we got to find
out
what classes can i take and there's
there's all kinds of online cheap
options
the ken coleman show partners with an
organization called bethel tech
you need to call bethel tech today as
soon as this call is over
say hey i just talked to ken coleman on
the dave ramsey show and he tells you
guys got a program it's really
affordable they'll let you cash flow it
and in less than nine months they get
you ready to be a full-time
coding professional and you don't even
need that but that's one option that's
just
one there are other many plethora of
options out there
where you can learn how to code so
that's what you would do with that extra
time right now
is invest in yourself become trained to
be
a somebody who codes and then go okay
what kind of coding work would i most
like to do
what's available in pocatello uh and so
now all of a sudden
we just start going that direction we go
hey i'm qualified
and i'm here this is how many hours a
week i can do it and if it's part time
fine if it's a full-time gig that they
allow you to do remote that's perfect
for you as well but that's just
one example of how you could step into
something you've always wanted to do
and now it becomes a labor of love that
also makes you some extra dough
thoughts on that questions no i think
that's great yeah like you said it's a
blank canvas so i
i think part of it's just overwhelming
even though we're even you know knowing
where to start
because it's like wow there's so many
things i could do and you know there are
lots of things i've kind of wanted to
experiment with like coding is one of
them but
it's just kind of overwhelming like
where to start well but again don't let
it be overwhelming you're making it
overwhelming
what i just broke it down for you i made
coding not so overwhelming yes or no
yes because what did i do i simply took
the unknown out of the equation john and
i were just talking about this on the on
the break
when we as human beings don't know
something that fear of the unknown is
paralyzing it's the number one fear i
think certainly in the space that i'm in
where people go
oh and it's like wait a second if i go
get qualified
while i'm getting qualified the people
that are qualifying me are going to tell
me all the different types of jobs that
i'm just now getting qualified for nick
ding ding ding ding they give you a
catalog if you will to sift through then
you actually
while you're getting qualified guess
what you're doing it's stage three
of my seven stages to meaningful work
stage one is get clear you're clear
coding is an option it might be another
one two or three you said stage two is
get qualified to do that work
stage three is i'm getting connected
while i'm getting qualified john i can
be in stage two and stage three at the
same time i'm making connections
i'm meeting people who are in coding in
pocatello i mean people
companies that are doing it i'm walking
in going hey look i got a full-time job
i'm a big shot pilot
but i love coding i'm looking for some
extra work 20 25 hours i'm getting
qualified right now just want to say hi
real quick if you ever need somebody a
little remote work i'm your gotcha
hey nick here's another thing to keep in
your back pocket
and i don't talk about this i don't
think i've ever talked about this on the
show um we talk a lot about i went to a
lot of grad school didn't have a lot of
friends and so i've got two big fancy
degrees
i also started a mft program in my early
20s
and i got in and i dropped it i started
a theology program
took some classes wasn't my thing didn't
dig it
human development family studies i
wanted to learn how people grew and how
families grew together
i just i didn't i didn't dig it it
wasn't my thing so i took some classes
and i and i
wasn't for me the temptation here nick
is to feel like you have to pick the one
or it's over no that's right and here i
am 20 years later
15 years later i love what i'm doing man
it's just silly
i got their credentials and i was
dumb enough to stick my nose in a bunch
of different thing
things and find out which ones i liked
which ones i didn't so you tried a
coding class you don't like it
yeah i'm not into coding man i thought
it was i checked it out it's not for me
you still got a paycheck you're still
rocking pocatello and then you go on to
the next thing and the next thing and
the next thing right
it's keeping your those options open man
yeah and the same process nick if you've
got other ideas run it out
what would i need to do to get qualified
to do those things how much is that
going to cost me
how long is that going to take and now
you've got yourself another plan
and that's how that works and by the way
john and i are dead serious if you want
to run by the old high school there and
get us uh i'd like a hoodie
um you want the t-shirt sure it's good
for me uh and i'll send you a check uh
for the cost of the hoodie i'm a big
hoodie fan yeah we'll hook you up man
the pocatello high school
thunder if i rocked one of those in
downtown franklin it'd be the only one
the only one yeah i like that yeah i
like
that a lot you know john we were talking
about that i want to expound on this a
little bit this idea of the fear of the
unknown
i i talk about it from a practical
standpoint here's how you get over it
we dive into that but talk about the
psychology behind that why is it so
gripping
i think it one of the core's core
principles that everyone navigates and
stumbles through life is
i want to be fully known i want you to
know me and see me
and i want you to love me and we hedge
the front end of that
because we're scared of the second part
of that i'm not going to really tell you
what i think about this i'm not going to
tell you my true fears i might
i'm because i'm nervous you're not going
to love me so i'm going to go halfway
i'm going to tell you most things and
can i talk to couples who've been
married for
decades they don't fully talk to each
other because i don't if i go all
in man that's a vulnerability level i'm
not comfortable with and so they just
they don't
but the only the problem with that is
the only way you can truly ever be
captivated and loved is by being all in
right and there's that fear
and we have we just it's innate in us
that we want to be loved and we're
scared and so we hold back
and we just stumble stumble stumble you
have to say
i'm gonna just go because every
relationship every job
every move is a risk every marriage is a
risk having a kid is a risk
every relationship is a risk and it's
gonna hurt you're gonna have times when
you
you weep and it's and it's hard and
there is nothing
richer and more important for our lives
than to be connected and be in
relationship with other people
period it's all a risk that's right you
gotta go man you just gotta jump and go
all right hey don't move more of
your calls your big life questions
coming up this is the dave ramsey show
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
the dave ramsey show continues i'm ken
coleman joined by dr john dilloni we're
ramsay personalities we also host
shows named after us doc the dr john
delano show
the kid coleman show yes we know how
creative those names are but they are
designed to help you and they do
if you want to check out more about what
john is doing in the show
you need to check him out on youtube and
wherever you listen to podcast
and the website is www.johndeloni.com do
you know you don't have to say www
anymore
you aware that everybody on the planet
knows that if you just say
kencoleman.com listen they know
that um and by the way you don't even
actually have to type that in what can
you do i'm going to show you speak it
now
yeah well we're just we're just going to
do this real quick so see here i'm in a
web window and i'm just going to type in
ken and look at it look at that i didn't
have to do any www
so the next time somebody asks you to
promote your website
do you don't have to you in your little
magic box over here can do whatever
y'all want to do
all this stuff i just know that that's
funny that you still did the www
is that because you're from texas you
just like to say that people think i'm
playing
i don't like spending time
in front of these magic boxes and in the
the okay
well that's www.fantasylife.com on the
social medias well it's consistent with
who
you are all right well you got to check
out the like john delaney show
uh it's it's great fantastic stuff also
check out
the ken coleman show as well and
www.kencoleman.com
thank you that's great for everybody
that's over 65 they're very grateful
that you just shared that information
with them type in a typewriter triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number let's go
to christian who joins us in denver
colorado christian how can we help
all right guys it's an absolute honor to
talk to you guys i really appreciate you
taking my call
you bet how can we help all right sorry
i'm nervous
oh don't i kind of have all right
um so i kind of have a question excuse
me that kind of tested on
all your guys's fancy personality quest
um so
long story short i found out about dave
anthony and you guys um
about two years ago um when gazellington
sold my first time chevy truck that i
absolutely loved and
saved 550 bucks a month um and then
of course 2020 happens and i know 2020
was
rough on everybody but for me in
particular it
about just destroyed me mentally um long
story short
about 75 000 in debt
um and i uh have a three-year-old and a
one-year-old
um and we just found out that we're
having twins so
so i'm getting a little emotional here
sure um
but yeah so i'm just looking for
guidance on where to go and what to do
next and some wisdom um
in 2020 and are you married man yes
okay happily you're doing okay
they are very happily so we just found
out i have a twin so they're going to be
our third and fourth kids and i'm
pretty terrified and excited but
um yeah so in 2020 i got lot i got fired
from the oil and gas job
um early early january because of covert
and government restrictions and all that
crap
um found another job and got fired from
that because my dad
sorry my dad passed away from als with
garrett's disease in february
2020. and uh sorry
um so anyways um i'm gonna total my car
and all i said just life
um but so i'm looking to see where i
should go next
and the baby steps um especially with
the twins come in on
and only um on babysit two so i just i
just don't know what to do
are you employed right now i am yeah i
got a job
after unemployment um at the post office
usps which is awesome
um i mean i'm working like 70 80 hours a
week
what are you what are you what's your
income right now
uh well the holiday season which was i
mean it wasn't really a slow season
because it covered with the post office
but during the holiday season which kind
of sort of just ended i was working like
80 hours a week
um now i'm you know still 65 70 hours a
week so
how much are you making give me a
ballpark idea what your monthly income
is
um well so my we just switched over to
my insurance
um so after that's taken out like
depending on if i'm working 60 or 70
hours a week it's roughly about
2 200 a paycheck twice a month okay
that's your take home yeah okay well all
my wife's paycheck has
now goes to she works at daycare where
both our two little kids go so pretty
much even with half off daycare she gets
like less than 200 bucks a month all
right
paycheck hey so listen you you
walked us through a couple of things and
then you just
tossed aside and said hey that's just
life let's just move on and i want to
stop there for a second
you've got a pause brother and grieve
this you lost your old man
i could tell in your voice that you love
that guy
you wanted him to see these twins
and he's not going to and don't gloss
that over man
okay
his memory is powerful and important to
you and he's going to miss an important
thing and that's heartbreaking and if
you just blow by that man your body will
not let you forget that
okay it will haunt you
okay you got fired and then you got up
you dusted yourself off
and you got fired again and you got up
and you dusted yourself off and you
climb back again
and so this has been an ugly gnarly
season of loss
this isn't just life it is it happens
but don't go comparing yourself to other
people look in the mirror and say
brother this year sucked his heart
and then when you have a season of
grieving
which you have to have you have to have
it
and you got to do it with other people
you got to get a guy or two in your life
that you can be as open as you're being
to two strangers on the radio right now
that will sit there with you then you're
gonna start making meaning of this stuff
on the back end and then you know what's
gonna happen
you're gonna realize dude i found out
i'm six inches taller than i thought i
was
i got knocked down twice and i got back
up again i buried my old man
and i became a father i doubled my my
child load
right and those kids are going to scare
the crap out of you and they're going to
be the greatest blessing all in the same
thing because that's what kids
are right yeah
and y'all are grinding and accomplishing
so much good stuff and it just feels so
heavy because you got to sit down and
just
absorb and feel this for a season okay
yeah yeah i feel like i haven't had a
chance to breathe or do anything just
work work work
you're right you're right and hey you
know what sometimes you got to do that
you got mouths to feed you've got you
are a man of character and perseverance
and integrity
you're right but if you don't stop your
body will stop you
so christian here's the deal your baby
steps
don't change none of this changes so
you've got
75 000 in debt and so you're through
baby step
one and so you and your wife have got to
sit down and you do need to grieve and
and you know maybe you're not maybe you
take a week where you're not gonna work
those crazy hours and
and you just get some time to breathe
and begin the healing process like john
said but
i gotta tell you something i want you to
understand that the fear you're feeling
um it while it's natural i'm telling you
it's not real you can do this
and if your wife has got to say you know
what i'm going to have to get a
different job
to where the money i'm making it all
doesn't go to the daycare and what else
can she do and what
what can we do to say all right we're
going to get gazelle intense together
and it's not all on you working 70 or 80
hours
okay uh but you're gonna work the baby
steps exactly the way we teach them
you're in baby step two
and so we're going to incrementally
we're going to be disciplined we're
going to keep going at this we're going
to get gazelle intent so we're going to
knock
that debt out and you guys will be able
to do this but you need more income
because here's the reality i got three
kids
and i know that when we went from one to
two that was a big adjustment but two to
three wasn't really that big a deal i
know you got twins and i know that's
intimidating but listen
you guys are man-to-man defense right
now anyway you know what to do
there's nothing new coming at you per se
but you've just got to double down and
go all right
you got to go to zone now right that's
it now well they're in the power plant
the kids the kids are in the power play
man you're one man down
uh but you're not the first couple to
have to do that and i believe you guys
are really really strong and you know
what i'm looking at
that really impresses me about you
christian yes
is that you went through a tremendous
amount of pain last year and yet you're
still
standing brother you're still standing
and there's no shame in pain
in fact there's coming a day christian
or you're gonna rub your finger over
those scars like i got on my hand right
here where i got 15 stitches
and i can remember how i got that scar
it was painful but jon and healed
that's right i could touch that scar and
i don't wince
christian i want you to sit down this
weekend and i want you to write your dad
a letter
tell him that you're scared tell him
that you miss him tell him that you wish
you could meet these boys
tell me you'll love him and that you'll
see him again
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm ken
coleman ramsey personality and host of
the ken coleman show on the ramsey
solutions
network i'm joined by my colleague dr
john deloney host of the dr john delony
show
also a part of the ramsey solutions
network we're here taking your calls
uh i want to talk about something that's
really really important because we get
this call
every day uh here on the dave ramsey
show people looking to buy their first
home when do i buy the first home what's
the financial
you know implications of this so if
that's you and you're ready to buy your
first home
we want to make sure that you know now
is a great time if you're financially
ready due to the low mortgage interest
rates so keep in mind a lot of other
buyers out there
hoping to get that first home or upgrade
with the low rate
and so it's going to be competitive so
you need a top real estate agent in your
area
like one of our endorsed local providers
or elps our elp agents bring years of
success and experience to the table
they listen to your needs answer your
questions and they're going to be
committed to making sure your first home
is a blessing for many many years if
you're looking for that kind of an agent
go to daveramsey.com agents and find a
trusted agent near you that's
daveramsey.com
agents and ken i always i always like to
just put it out there we
yes we we sell stuff here that's how we
pay our bills
but i personally used one of those oh
yeah elp real estate agents and it was
phenomenal it was an extraordinary
experience
yeah well this is true of good entire
endorsed local provider programs those
are folks we use we
vet these folks tremendously and so if
you the people
don't have a good experience with those
folks you tell us and we kick them out
right and so it really is a trusted
network and uh
to have somebody that knows you're part
of the ramsey tribe
um and that they're gonna treat you with
just tremendous tremendous
care that's the way to go hey the phone
number to jump in is triple eight eight
two five
five two two five let's go to lisa next
and she is joining us in denver colorado
lisa how can we help
hi thanks for taking my call um i
had a question um
some bad things happened to me in 2020
and i'm ready for a change
um i'm my husband and i are
in a good place financially
i don't want to mess that up by um you
know we're considering moving to
california
it gives me a lot of pause because
everybody's leaving california
um um california
has some tax things on the horizon that
scare me
um so i just want to make sure i'm not
that a we can afford it and you know
i'm not doing something that's going to
set me up for failure why do you want to
move to california because the way you
couched this entire question is i had
some bad things happen to me
and it kind of feels like bad things
happen we want to get out of our current
zip code is that what's going on and
then what do you feel comfortable
telling me about that
um i was physically attacked um i'm just
i'm in a city where like murders are
happening in the park down the street
oh my goodness um you know it's just
become
yeah well that answers the village
progressive
yeah and the trauma associated
permissive
it's crazy yeah um i don't have a lot of
family
so place is really important to me i
feel at home
in the place that i sorry if you asked
me that question i was going to start to
cry
i know you're good it's okay it's okay
because we need to understand your why
why california and then what we do is we
go okay
what has to be true to make that happen
because
everything you're bringing up is all
legitimate and a legitimate concern
so where in california are you thinking
yeah beautiful place and why santa
barbara
um it's i have history there um
i spent part of my life growing up there
um the other part of this is
we can move overseas to some pretty
fantastic places
um but my husband's work from home now
and his
company is based in california and just
with the time differences
he doesn't feel he would be productive
um like on zoom calls and stuff if he
was working in the middle tonight
all right let me let me hop in real
quick hey so uh lisa when
when were when was this traumatic event
what when was this
um october okay you know by a couple i
mean
i just don't it's just you can't walk
down the street here without
seeing drug use anymore or sure um
you know hey listen you don't you don't
have to
prove you don't have to convince us
right i can hear it in your voice
you're ready to go okay what i want you
to do
is to you got to find a place to go and
if california is a place ken's going to
walk you through the transition and all
that
what i'm going to tell you is going to
sound insensitive and i want you to hear
my heart
as i'm telling you this okay wherever
you move
lisa is going to go there too
yeah i know i think part of the moving
is for healing
is if it would heal me and what i'm
telling you
i don't feel safe it it won't okay
it will keep you safer it won't heal you
you're gonna have to confront the the
the
lack of safety you're going to have to
confront that trauma you're going to
have to do that work
and through connection with your husband
through relationships probably through a
therapist
and probably go get a professional to
walk you through some of this a change
of place will will
provide you some relief but it won't
heal you
and that's why i tell you wherever you
go you're going with you
and so i do want you to find a place
where you can transition to ken walker
through that
yeah so here's the deal your husband his
he's working from home
and his company is in california so he's
gonna he's already got a job
and it's a simple move for him so no
interruption and income am i assuming
correctly yeah and i would
i would be able to transition as well
even though i work with the public
oh and we make around 200 000 a year
oh well sweetheart okay great news okay
california is more expensive but on a
household income of 200 000 you guys
aren't going to struggle
um so that i want to relieve you on that
but what you can do just so you can see
what the cost of living is really going
to look like
you guys can actually look in santa
barbara and surrounding areas
you know and it's like getting out the
old realtor.com is one of my favorite
websites
and you just kind of look at it you go
okay what what does housing look like to
do real math
do real math with rental costs plus a
purchasing situation based on your home
situation we go okay
this is what we're really looking like
uh what this is
this is what uh a cost of living
for our our home is gonna look like then
we go all right
let's call let's go to daveramsey.com
and let's find
a couple of tax elps out in in the los
angeles area and call them go hey
i'm a dave ramsey show listener you're a
tax elp uh can you walk me through the
tax changes that i'm hearing about
and they'll be able to because they're
experts in california on state taxes
they can tell you what you guys are
looking at you can tell them what you
did last year your w-2s
and kind of walk through that and you're
going to get a really good picture and
so lisa i've got to tell you
all of your concerns are valid but you
can go get
real answers to plug into a real budget
and go oh this is what it's actually
going to cost us this is where we might
have to tighten
or this is where you know maybe we just
make a different decision
and live a little bit differently uh in
the type of home out there
but all of that is easily uh acquired
information are you tracking with me
yeah i mean we um we own a home outright
and we have no debt so we'll be able to
put
like 750 oh my gosh yeah you can do
whatever you want oh i knew you were in
good shape i didn't know you were in
that good shape
i see really wealthy people leaving
california just
terrified of what's coming down the
pipeline well but lisa lisa that's all
real
and that's a part of the equation you
you have to weigh that like
john and i can't tell you ah forget what
those people are thinking no
they're leaving for a reason they're
leaving because of the the higher taxes
and because of
a lot of things and i'm just gonna be
really honest with you you need to do
your homework go go read the la times go
go watch the local news i mean uh dig i
mean there's a lot of uh
stuff going on in los angeles right now
that didn't look like this
a year and a half ago i don't think lisa
i don't think you want to go to
california
i think you have some good memories
there and it feels like a safe home base
you just want to escape denver you want
to get out of denver i'd start looking
around in other places that may be warm
i think though i think the whole
nation's open to you guys be a fun date
night let's just dream
let's discover together let's get a
laptop out man a couple glasses of wine
and go where would we want to go where
could we go with this kind of
million dollars in kansas hello come on
man come on
man we're talking country club you know
what i'm saying yes
all right i'm not a country club guy but
yes lisa we're sorry for you but you're
going to be
okay hey i want to say a big thanks to
my colleague dr john dolone i want to
say thanks to our producer james childs
our associate producer today zach
bennett and you america
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the dave ramsey show it's where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life
and your money i'm kent coleman host of
the ken coleman show on the ramsey
solutions network joined by my colleague
dr john deloney
host of the dr john delaney show on the
ramsey solutions network as well and
we're here together today
we're taking your calls uh as we always
do but we're going to add in
our specialties john is obviously
working with folks on mental and
emotional health and relationships and
just
being whole as a person on the doctor
dr john delony show and then i'm going
to help you with
answering that age-old question why am i
here what should i do with my life and
we're going to look at the work
context you were created to fill a
unique role you were needed you must
do it and if you're sick and tired of
being miserable on monday mornings
life is too short to live for the
weekends uh
we're gonna take those questions as well
and john and i both love to take on
all these things together there's such a
collaboration between us when we do
shows
together and uh so we've taken calls uh
uh about toxicity at work politics and
family politics of the family unhealthy
leaders above us what do we do there
uh as well as our specialty as well and
we'll take your money questions too so
come on let's go we're having a blast
triple eight eight two five five two two
five i gotta tell uh
the youtube audience because they're out
there watching and looking at us the
producers and uh the engineers were
making fun of us during the last break
saying they were going to have a picnic
on us
after the show today because of the
flannel we did not plan this this was
not
it's time to be honest ken texted me
this morning said hey brother wear your
checkered flannel let's do it together
let's wear flannels today we're wearing
a blanket yeah no
never happened that is fake news hashtag
fake news triple eight eight two five
very conservative of you
ken oh stop it i'm just gonna stop it
all right let's see here oh boy we now
i'm hooked on phonics doc
but i'm going to take a shot at this one
sean is joining us in
mississauga ontario let's see if i'm
right sean how can we help
hey how you guys doing good did i say
that correctly
well yeah that's uh that's my nickname
my real name is a lot longer so i just
said yeah just go ahead and use my
nickname
oh okay we'll go with that i don't know
what any of that means
how can we help so so let me tell you
guys uh i'm 16 years old
um i've been an entrepreneur since i've
been 12.
i run two successful e-commerce
companies wow
and uh i also do stock trading uh kind
of on the side
and uh to get my social skills before i
am 18 i
also work at mcdonald's so
a lot to take in but i i really have a
good question for you guys okay go for
it
so um my parents have kind of you know
done a path for me to go to university
right after i graduate
whether i'm a millionaire or a
billionaire or worth nothing
so what do you guys recommend in this
sense i i feel like not going
to get a pulse a post-secondary
education and uh continuing the path
that i'm continuing and doing what i
love
yeah i want to know play that out and
you're a young man who
has got a lot on the ball but dream with
me a little bit as a 16 year old today
what's that dream take me 25 30 years
down the road what's that look like
um i'm gonna tell you uh we used me and
uh our family used to live in uh fresno
california
and we used to do house flipping there
and it was pretty successful until uh
our immigration status changed and we
had to move to canada so
i think i think based on what i've seen
from my dad doing and uh the business
skills and the business strategies he's
used i think
uh real estate would be would be good
for me in that pathway if i've saved up
enough money okay
so no so let me answer your question by
giving you
a framework to take to your mom and dad
because your mom and dad have saved up
for you to go to university and sounds
like they would really like you to do
that is that correct
not really not really i saved up for
myself oh good so
mom and dad aren't like super what's
their opinion on a scale of one to ten
one they don't care ten they'd really
love for you to go to university where
are they at
oh no it's more like 12 because i've
been to 11 countries
because my dad might idea what's called
works that i used to work at oil company
okay and uh it's all been about
education i'm from yemen so my
background is nice oh okay there you go
all right so you could tell all right so
sean and i'm gonna let john
jump in here in a second and give you
some thoughts on the relational
component about how you share this
but i want to give you at least a
framework to share with your mom and dad
so that they at least know you've
thought through this i know you don't
want to go
to university but you can just say i
talked to ken coleman
on the dave ramsey show and here's his
criteria
by which he gives advice on whether or
not you should go to university or not
two simple questions is it the only way
for you to get qualified
to do what it is you want to do is it
the only way the second question is
is it the best way so is it the only way
or the best way for you to be a
successful real estate professional
and work your way up so let's say you
got into just selling homes
right out of high school and you started
crushing it the way you've crushed
everything else you do
and you start making money and you cash
flowing you're saving like crazy and you
save up for your first flip
and you buy a house and i'm making this
up for round numbers
for 120 000 fix it up and flip it for
180
and you keep doing that while you're
successful you don't need to ever darken
the door of
a college campus to be qualified or
to be a successful real estate
professional
college isn't going to teach you that so
if you were my son i'd go is this what
you want to do
why do you want to do it and i'd walk
you through it and you'd give me all the
answers and if i felt good about i go
well here's the path
and the path for you is even now at 16
to see if you can find a local real
estate agent who will mentor you and let
you do
cleaning up their houses that they're
getting ready to sell and then and then
they teach you and
and and you learn from them and do
coffee with them each week or whatever
uh and you become a sponge and then
eventually you get qualified to be a
real estate agent and a couple of those
uh real estate professionals who've
mentored you eventually become your
broker you get into it
so if i'm going to sit on mom and dad i
want to be able to make a
practical case as to why i'm not going
but john i want you to speak to
the relationship component here when mom
and dad are really passionate about him
going to university
so sean do you love your folks
uh yeah man i mean i love them that they
did all this just for one reason to you
know get me into into education
and me saying hey you know i understand
you guys want me to
go into computer science but i'm more
interested in being an entrepreneur
right real estate that's kind of like
hold on
so you're telling me we have to travel
all around the world spend all that
money
get here when our immigration status
changed in california just so you could
tell us this
so i understand where they're coming
from it's just how can i right
away here i'm going to tell you
something that's going to be hard to
hear
okay so are you track with my my promise
to you is this
i've talked to thousands of high school
kids over the last
couple of decades and i love high school
kids and i'm not gonna lie to you okay
all right here's number i'm gonna tell
you a couple of things number one
you're 16 and i want you to remember
that
so when you talk to somebody who is um
an elder somebody who loves you i want
you to just
default to they've got wisdom that you
may not have
and that humility will serve you
relationally forever okay
now i know it's hard to hear because
right now you're just absolutely
dominating things
number two you gotta get some friends
and enjoy being 16
okay work and work and working i love
the hustle
right i love the hustle number three you
know there's a cultural component to
education
as ken said when you approach your
parents do it humbly and with gratitude
and with a firm plan
and number four dave ramsey himself went
ahead and went to college and sold
houses while he was a student it wasn't
an either or thing and so don't box
yourself into
have to or don't have to you can
accomplish both of them at the same time
if it's going to be something your
parents are going to require of you as a
kid but i love ken's idea
have a firm plan and sit down with
humility and grace
don't spend the money to do computer
science because mom and dad want you no
not computer subjects especially
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high
quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
dr john deloney as we take your
questions triple eight
eight two five five two two five take
talking life talking money talking
relationships talking
work you know one of the ways to get out
of debt faster is to get a bigger shovel
uh and that's what we talk about on the
ken coleman show is getting promoted
you know we see john uh day after day
with debt free screams that
the income range always goes up it's
fascinating i've never heard a debt free
screen where the income didn't go up
some
uh and that that that intense focus so
john and i are here to talk money life
work relationships
attention over political talk uh
toxicity in the workplace john and i
love to take on those together
but let's talk about the fact that many
of you are still trying to pay off debt
you feel like it's going to take forever
but now that we're into a new year it's
time to get some new energy and new
focus
and here's the truth paying off your
debt won't take as long as you think it
will
with ramsay plus you're going to get
where you want to go faster
debt free and spending your money
without worry ramsey plus guides you
through three apps that work together to
help you pay off your debt
as fast as possible you can make more
progress on your debt than you ever have
get ramsey plus and start living the
life you want
faster to start your free trial of
ramsay plus text the word trial
two three three seven eight nine text
the word trial
to three three seven eight nine let's go
to dayton ohio next where kyle joins us
kyle
how can we help good afternoon dr d and
ken how are you guys today
we're having a blast what's going on so
um well me and my wife have been doing
dave ramsey plan now
for about five years we're finishing up
baby step two and we've had to hit pause
because of a bit of a family crisis
um anybody who watched the reset event
will understand this
so i have a 43 year old yolo pig brother
who just retired from the military after
22 years
on the day of his retirement his wife
asked for a divorce
and left him three weeks later and
after that he didn't receive a paycheck
about six weeks the military messed up
his pay
and so him and his daughter i drove out
to delaware to pick him up
and him and his daughter moved into my
big brick house good for you kyle you're
a good brother man yeah
wait a step oh well thank you um so we
gave him
we gave him a couple weeks to kind of
take all of this in
um and then we sat him down trying to
talk to him about
the getting back on his feet money-wise
and watch the reset event we're starting
to go through
um financial peace with him we me and my
wife have uh ramsay plus
and so we're doing the online classes
with him i told him i said
you got to get a job you can't mope
around forever
i said i don't care if you don't find a
career right now but i need you to get
his job so he did he did finally get a
job
um but what we're what i'm trying to get
out to to find out today is
if there's different things we should be
doing or if what we're doing is the
correct thing
we've told him there we're we're gonna
have him stay here until at least june
when
his daughter's out of school uh she's in
fifth grade um that way she's not having
to switch back and forth between new
houses and all that along with all of
this
through all of this we've learned that
she has had a lot of trauma
mentally a lot of damage um as he has as
well but we've learned hers has gone on
for quite a few years
we're working on getting her into some
therapy we're going to get him into some
therapy
i'm just trying to see what else would
you guys recommend for us to do with
them or does this sound like a great
plan
so there's a couple of things here
number one i want to reiterate man um
you're a brother who's stepped up in a
time of need and i'm grateful that there
should be
i wish there were more brothers like you
in the country so i i'm
i'm grateful to know you're in our
community man um
so i want to step back 30 000 feet and
look at your brother
and you probably know this
intellectually but i want you to hear
this empathetically i want you to hear
this in your heart
your brother has lost everything but his
daughter
and i don't mean um tangibly
i mean identity he did the military for
this long that is who he was
right that's an identity and he'll tell
you that he was a married man with a
co-pilot and when you're married that
long somebody else is an arm and a leg
right and so he is recovering out of ash
and it's easy to um see that and say man
you got a couple of weeks brother you
got to get up and shake it off
i need you to hear and feel that he has
had
every single leaf shaken off that tree
and he's gonna have to grow from the
floor up
while also raising a daughter now that
should be enough why
but i don't want to minimize what a big
deal this is the second thing is
i want you to orient yourself in this
way
i want you and your wife to get some
really firm boundaries about dates
about time about money and then i want
you to keep this in the forefront of
your head
your brother is not a problem to fix
i don't want you to use the word damage
when you're talking to his daughter as
though she's a truck that hit a tree
absolutely yeah i would never mention
that to her right right but i want you
to
think of your brother and your niece as
somebody as people to be with
not as puzzles to solve and you're gonna
you heal you're gonna help me a part of
their healing journey you can't heal him
man he's got to decide he wants to do
this
but you can connect with him so you've
offered him a place to stay which is
above and beyond you're going to provide
some boundaries and structure for him
and some encouragement
and then you're just going to be with
him and you're going to hold firm to
those boundaries
but you're going to be with him and if
you can afford counseling for his
daughter
great if you can lean into some of those
things great but i want you to
let him know you are there to talk to
him but man he needs to go find a group
he needs to
he's got to have a professional to walk
through this season with him
and you can't do that walking for him
you can just encourage him and be with
him and be with him right
yeah kyle you're doing great the answer
is that's an
unbelievable amount of things you're
doing for your brother and because
you're in ramsey plus i'd bring him in
make sure he's here's the deal down the
line we're gonna give you ramsey plus
for
your brother look at that um stay on the
line zach's going to um
get it get his contact info so he has
his own he can have his own app and he
can
learn to use this stuff on his own and
not be hitched to his little brother but
other than that
i mean you've got you've got a great
plan here and that's wonderful the only
thing is is over time you know as he's
just
reentering the workforce i would tell
him to listen to my show
let him listen to it's a podcast just
recommend it he can watch it on youtube
let's help him figure out what his sweet
spot is outside of the military what his
contribution zone is uh because that
will bring tremendous meaning you know
we talked about this earlier
john and i uh john texted me something
on saturday morning
um and and we know from from from
psychology studies and
the neuroscience and all this you were
reading some stuff that uh
being without a job or not having some
type of connection to your work
is is trauma on the level of losing a
loved one and he's already gone through
trauma with the divorce
right um and so he's in a heavy heavy
time so helping him
find some joy in his work
will allow him to heal i believe faster
with the therapy of course and coming
home and be able to give himself fully
to his daughter where he feels like okay
i've got this
right but but coming home to a brother
who's judging him is going to hurt
no right he's this guy's not kyle's not
going to judge him
no but kyle's a guy who's going to come
up with a good plan yeah and he's gonna
say
you're following the plan you follow the
plan and i want kyle to be a
a great boundary setter i want kyle to
be
that great brother but i wanted to come
home and say dude it's so good to see
you man yeah of course
i'm gonna give you a hard hug yep hard
hug man and then once we get the kids to
wed
we're gonna go on the back porch and
just hang out yeah cause you're my
freaking brother yeah i love you
does that make sense of course it makes
sense i think it's the right thing you
know i don't sense any judgment
kyle and i think john what you're saying
and kyle what you got to get here is
don't be
over zealous you're not dad now yeah
your brother you've offered him these
things
he's a big boy to your point john and uh
you know on the back porch you're going
to say brother you've got two months
left
yeah you can remind him he's got to go
but you're loving on him and go man i'm
so excited about the next chapter and
reminding himself doing some fun things
with him you know what you guys used to
do with brothers
i think it'd be fun to recreate some of
that you know i know my brother came in
town for thanksgiving and
did y'all toilet paper a house we did
not man uh you can't do that anymore
i love you that's where you go i i i'm
taking us to some hallmark moment and
you interrupt and say
did you guys go tp somebody's house no
we went and played putt-putt miniature
golf because we used to compete
and so we were out there with my dad it
was like it was like time had suspended
and we went back you know
do some of that brotherly love stuff
where you guys remember
being innocent and there wasn't divorce
and there wasn't all kinds of problems
it was just
we're bros man you and me that's right
you know and i think that's a really
good thing to do but you're a good man
i'm going to nominate kyle for brother
of the year so
uh send your votes to i don't know where
pocatello idaho
pocatello idaho yes i need that hoodie
man
all right listen we're still just
getting warmed up we're not even close
to done
more of your calls more of your
questions more breakthrough
more hope coming up on the dave ramsey
[Music]
show
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out at
chministries.org
[Music]
[Music]
the dave ramsey show continues i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
deloney as we take your calls triple
825-5225
hey you need to find out for yourself
why blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window covering
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsay to get the best deals
rules and restrictions apply today's
question comes from
kristin indiana in indiana she says i've
been in my job for almost 10 years
and i make about 65 000 a year and i'm
about halfway through
baby step three i enjoy most of my job
but i have some very stressful duties
that i don't enjoy about my job
as well is it worth looking elsewhere
and taking a pay cut to reduce stress
and ultimately be happier at my job
currently i'm looking at a pay cut of
about twenty thousand dollars all right
in this situation kristen because you
are
so close to getting through baby step
three
which gets that fully funded emergency
fund that's three to six months
is what we teach here at ramsey
solutions that's such a big milestone
and it's a game changer financially in
this situation i would not
currently take a pay cut of about twenty
thousand dollars
i'm okay with pay cuts only
when you have to go backwards to get in
but there is a short term sacrifice and
you know that you're going to climb the
ladder and eventually replace that
income
and you're in a financial position i.e
you're not in debt you've got an
emergency fund and you've you've made
some changes in your budget
to be able to absorb that pay cut and
you're not going backwards so in this
situation here's what i want you to do
is it worth looking elsewhere absolutely
but let's keep on looking
because you enjoy most
of your job that's a good thing kristin
i talk to people every day on the ken
goldman show hate every part
of their job so can i weigh in here uh
yeah in just a second
okay all right last part i'm i'm good no
but here's the last part
because she enjoys most of her job um
what i'm doing is i'm looking for
something that she can step into
that doesn't have as big of a pay cut 20
000 a little bit too big i'm wanting her
to look around some more
and then do some other things to try to
reduce that stress
that she is dealing with that that would
be my position on that one yes sir go
ahead weigh in please
so you you take calls about jobs all the
time
um i used to have conversations with my
college students for years and years
about job quality
yeah i'm i may be out to lunch here so
help me
is there such thing as a perfect job
that doesn't have
parts of the job that are stressful no
is a dream job mean
there's not certain forms that you have
to fill out that you hate that part
or that you got to do budgets at the end
of a term
well i'm in my dream job and there's
stuff i have to do here at ramsey
solutions sometimes there's certain days
where i've got to do
five to ten percent yeah that's one that
itches our face
i have to sneeze i don't know how hours
i don't know how women do that's
incredible
because i can't wait to take that makeup
off it is itchy
uh first of all i don't know what i'm
doing if you get up close to me
and please don't social distance in and
all exactly
it looks like i've put it on like cake
batter because i don't know how they do
it all i do is i just rub that thing
around and dave conveniently left that
part out of
any of my interviews that was not in any
of the
interviews that we would wear makeup
when we're on stage under the lights or
in these bright studios but we digress
we lost
we got off track but there are things in
every job
yes that just because it's hard just
because it's crappy just because
you have to do it every day or every
month doesn't mean it's not your dream
job that's right
well that's exactly right so i said look
you love most of your job
be a big girl put your big girl pants on
and let's figure out how to deal with
that but if it is something that is
toxic
and she loves most of the job but there
is toxicity that's eventually going to
wear you down you know that
so in that situation i go let's start
looking
but until then let's have an attitude of
gratitude so that's my feeling what do
my emotions need to be i'm grateful for
this job and what it provides to me
right uh stability and safety and a
launching pad
if we need to move and then my mindset
needs to be
you know what i enjoy most of my job i
can figure out a way to
deal with difficult people or difficult
circumstances right yes you're
absolutely right okay
yeah and by the way people say all the
time ken uh is it okay if it's a dream
job if i love eighty percent
i go yeah absolutely again
you do what you have to do to do what
you want to do love it you know which
sometimes
i really like making money i hate paying
taxes
i don't get to just say well now this
tax thing
right it really stresses me out i i
don't like this
right see how that works out for you
or the marriage part we haven't hold
this fight i'm out obviously this you
weren't the one because we had a
disagreement
i love date night and romance but i
don't like this
fighting and you reminding me that i
left my socks in the bathroom again oh
you want me to bathe
every week well then you're not the one
from no dude everything's got hard stuff
in it right
that's it be a grown up man all right
let's go solving problems
we are washington needs to call us yeah
and the depth of that advice by the way
was you know it's exactly it's worth
every penny people paid for it
good call let's go to mike who's waiting
for us in los angeles california mike
how can we help
hey guys how's it going today we're
having fun what's going on with you how
can we help you
i'm coming in today to see where i
should
really take the next step i'm 22 right
now and i finished up college last year
i don't have a job and i got my
undergraduate degree in a field that i'm
second guessing which is law
and i don't know if i should start a
nine to five or work for myself
by investing since i have about 120 000
in cash
available to me right now and paid off
all my debt no car payment and i live at
home
what do you guys recommend wow mike okay
so you're in a good position i didn't
expect to hear that
from the 22 year old unemployed college
grad um
when you say work for yourself by
investing unpack that a little bit more
give me some details what's that look
like in your head
sure in my head that looks more like
investing in real estate either through
property flipping or purchasing home and
renting them out
or possibly opening a business and the
thing is i wouldn't know what that
business would be
yeah so i don't know what direction to
walk toward okay great so
you have some general ideas and so what
i want you to do is a process called
clarify and verify
and this is uh this is in the book the
proximity principle my best-selling book
i'm gonna give you a copy of it okay
when we're done with the call
so that this is going to walk you
through this all right but here's the
point
i want you to start now again los
angeles is in lockdown so
we've got an asterisk here with this
advice but when you can start getting
out and
shadowing some real estate professionals
people who flip homes maybe some
contractors guys that build homes some
successful realtors
i i kind of like you at 22 you're in
good financial
shape and you're living at home i kind
of like you getting a job for a
successful real estate professional
uh either a developer or a realtor who
dips in you know kind of sells homes
brokers homes
but also does some flipping themselves
and i like you just taking an hourly job
for them
and becoming a human sponge you learn it
all everything and here's that's where
clarify verify comes in i learned
everything there is to learn about this
particular piece of this
because real estate professional is one
piece of it right land developers
another piece
uh corporate office developers another
dealing with general contractors general
contractors is another piece
and by you tr uh following excuse me
uh uh working for somebody they're
paying you
to get a master's degree and actually
running that business and you find out
oh
i thought i wanted to run this for
myself i thought i wanted to flip houses
it's way more fun on hgtv yeah i don't
actually like that
mike are you tracking with me so far
yes so that's what i want you to do i
want you doing a lot of clarifying and
verified i want you to get here's what
the proximity principle says
and i wrote an entire book on it and it
came out of the
the ken coleman show giving advice the
proximity principle says
in order to do what mike wants to do and
by the way we can keep plugging in some
different answers here so i like it
being fill in the blank
mike because you're 22. so now's the
time to explore and discover
so in order to do what mike wants to do
let's call it house flipper real estate
impresario okay mike's got to be around
people that do that
and are doing that and successfully by
the way
not in title only and these got to be in
places where that is happening so it's
people and places
here's the formula the right people plus
the right places
equals opportunity opportunity to learn
opportunity to do that would be the
experience so the education real time
education real street education
and then real experience and i go hmm
i do want to do this i've learned how to
do it i'm going to bust it and make some
money
and be really really smart and mike i
want to remind you i like the position
that you're in
but the ramsey way is you better keep
saving get to work you need a nine to
five pretty quick keep working keep
saving
pay cash for that first dump and then
flip it if that is in fact
the way you want to do it do it cash so
you can win hang on
my best selling book the proximity
principal is waiting for you zach will
take care of you for the rest of you
you hang on too we have more of the dave
ramsey show coming right up
[Music]
[Music]
the dave ramsey show continues on i'm
ken coleman joined by my colleague
john delony and we are taking your calls
triple eight
eight two five five two two five our
scripture of the day
romans 12 6 having gifts that defer
according to the grace given to us let
us
use them if prophecy in proportion
to our faith our quote of the day from
maya angelou
i did then what i knew how to do now
that i
know better i do better one of my
favorite quotes in the
whole wide world by the way if you ever
just want to feel good you're having a
dark day
you know and you're just like i'm tired
of negativity go just
do a little search for maya angelou on
youtube and just watch her drop some
gold
man you know that was a woman who had a
true gift with words
and uh a legend by the way i want to
mention
um we lost a we lost a legend today we
did
man a legend in the sports world and
also a man
defined in in in his latter years and
even in his career
uh uh by as much grace as as he had
talent and that's hank aaron
yeah heartbreaking man i mean a true
prince of a man
yeah um you know uh you think about what
happens
and experience things that what he
experienced we could never
understand and to break babe ruth's home
run record and the vitriol
and and the nastiness that he endured
and yet uh by all accounts and i lived
in atlanta area for 11 years
uh he's a legend of the world but
certainly he's a legend in the atlanta
area right
and uh sad to see that uh he passed away
today yeah it's a
hammer and hank just keeps coming man
your son's name is hank
it is yeah hammer and hank what a great
nickname yeah hank's one of thank
aaron's
best one of the classes humans to live
man really true yeah really true
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number let's go to burbank
california right in the heart of
hollywood
area benjamin is there benjamin how can
we help
hi guys thanks so much for taking my
call you bet what's going on
hey so i you know being in burbank i
work in the entertainment industry i
used to be a sound editor
for cartoons oh cool and it's a great
job
totally loved it pandemic it and you
know everything went to went to doo-doo
and so i was left with uh you know no
job
went to duty i'm not laughing at you i'm
laughing with you brother benjamin need
to understand that that
john his inner seven-year-old came out
when you said doo-doo there's no way he
was gonna make it through the segment
without laughing out loud
i'll give you that one all right
appreciate it so you were a sound editor
for cartoons and you got laid off uh
due to covet yeah pretty much
the you know basically furloughed so i
wonder
okay whenever whenever work comes back
we'll call you a type of thing okay
um so i was left out dry with okay
what do i do i just moved here i was
i've lived here for three months and
then the pandemic kid
is yeah and so i was going great
i'm out of college uh i graduated with
um
two degrees uh i mastered i'm sorry i
got my bachelor's in
music industry studies and i got another
bachelor's in finance
and so this show has been great uh i
totally love it so thank you guys for
having me you bet so what
yeah yeah so i have no debt i've got
about twenty four thousand
investments um i have two and a half
thousand in emergency funds
and i am currently in a place where i
started a business
um an online business uh where i sell
guitar picks with flowers inside them
it's been doing super well
and i came up with this idea on my own
and i was leaning okay well if all jobs
are
out in the middle of nothing i'm gonna
have to make my own job and so
i was doing this for a while and you
know
eating into my savings just to stay
alive and then all of a sudden in
november it began to pick up
and so i i
was running this job uh by my own
and uh just innovating and everything
like that now long here comes my friend
who hooks me up with a stay-at-home job
um i'm working part-time there and i was
able to kind of gather my feet a little
bit
so as i'm kind of gathering my feet
working part time for this one place
work from home i'm still running my
business
i'm working about one day a week and so
i'm seeing a lot of potential for this
business
and a lot of potential for growth i'm
working one day a week and i'm making
about
half of my monthly paycheck uh at this
part-time gup
which is how much give me a ballpark
number
so working part-time hourly i make about
something around like 2200 a month um
and if i run my business you know if i
put in one day's effort
in a week for my business i'll make
about at max
you know a thousand a month somehow will
it scale with you
meaning is that all it takes to fill the
pick orders you have or if you worked
every day like that would it scale up
that way
uh i believe it would scale up because
i'm constantly selling out of
stuff the only reason i'm not making
more sales is because i run out of stock
okay what are you doing in that one day
that's driving all of those sales so
that if you put in let's say two days a
week
or three days a week you you feel like
you're gonna see the sales come with
that
what are you doing right so my day to
day of working um
well i manufacture them uh and so that
takes about
i don't know an hour or two a day and
then the rest is just managing the
online store
the online store opens up you know i
just have
sales coming in okay so you're making
the guitar picks yourself so to john's
point
you know you're saying when you make
them
um but the orders are coming in even on
the days you're not working
correct correct yeah so if you make a
thousand dollars a month just working
one day a week
if you were to work five days a week
you'd make five thousand dollars a month
uh potentially i mean yeah that's a big
difference between
yes no that's not the case because
benjamin you're
making the picks so you're sitting there
in your apartment or wherever and you're
making the picks
and the orders are coming in regardless
so you making the picks themselves
doesn't make the orders come in more so
you could so that's that's
the scary part it's not going to scale
it's not going to it's not going to
scale like you think it is because
what's going to happen is is you need to
figure out what would cause the orders
to
to pick up so maybe i spent a little bit
more time working on the marketing piece
or the
you know or the social media advertising
piece or whatever
and let's get some more orders in but
before we do that let's go
what happens if my orders went up 10
15 20 maybe go 5
10 15 20 and go oh that means i'd have
to make this much at what point do you
become
uh limited in your ability to make the
picks and now you got to train somebody
else to do it does that make sense
benjamin
yeah totally and and i've been thinking
about all that too and
so well then here's my point i would
start easing into it
so so so once you've done that homework
and you said you've done it i'd go all
right
uh i'm going to spend a little bit more
time than one day a week
or i'm going to add an additional three
or four hours on that one day a week
and i'm going to focus on driving more
orders and let's see if that works i
would not commit to this thing full time
yet i would ease into it
let's see if we can incrementally
because you're the only manufacturer
right now
correct correct so that could be
eventually a problem a good problem
but it could also sync you so you've got
to think through this and let's go
incrementally on all right let's see if
i can raise my orders
and if i raise it by this much i can
still keep up with it at what point do i
get to a point where i need to train
somebody
how to make these picks with flowers in
them and as you're building this thing
dave spoke to the company dave ramsey
spoke to the company a few weeks ago
talking about
how he used to have to go early to
events and set all the chairs up to
himself
speak at the event sign books and talk
to everybody and then when everyone went
home
take all the stuff down himself and so
this idea that
you got to be doing a lot of both and is
what i'm saying yeah yeah when you're
building a new
niche market you got to do both and both
and you have late nights early mornings
for a long season
yep before this stuff takes off on it
and here's the temptation benjamin and
other entrepreneurs listen to me there's
a big temptation
because what he's doing has got some
real mo it's cool he's got some momentum
i mean he's making half you know he's
making about a thousand bucks
he starts to feel like oh i can go do
this i could scale this now no
stick every nickel that you're making
now
back into the business to prepare for
the long haul and the biggest mistake
that entrepreneurs make is they try to
go full time too
soon yes because we're excited about it
it's our idea people actually buying it
oh i want to get it out there and it's
like whoa
it's my favorite scene from braveheart
where the english army is thundering
down on william wallace
and his merry men from scotland they got
those long spears he goes hold
hold and the horses get closer hold
it's like hey hold there'll be a time to
go full time and it will
be very very evident you'll know it
that's right hey we had a blast
appreciate you doctor youtube man daloni
want to say thanks to our producer james
childs
our associate producer today zach
bennett and we want to thank you america
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
you